hey everyone I'm Cody Seibert and
welcome to a full-stack tutorial on how
to build a web application using vue.js
for the front-end express slash node.js
for the backend and then my sequel for
the database or sequel Lite as we do it
development locally and before I get
started to on this tutorial I want to
say that this tutorial might be a little
bit in the intermediate / advanced level
but if you are a beginner I'm going to
try to talk through everything I do and
repeat actions you know often so that
you can kind of bake it into your head
of how you'd build a full stack
application so hopefully you know first
time through of your beginner might be
confusing second time through you might
pick up on key things third time through
everything might make sense to you but
without further ado let's go and get
started so get an overview of what bjs
is it's a front-end library which is
used for building single page
applications and I'm on the view GS
website right now so if I go ahead and
click on get started here it navigates
us to their documentation which I
believe is some of the best Doc's I've
read for a library or framework in the
past I've worked with angular 1 I've
worked a little bit with angular 2 and
I've worked some with react and now I
want to say I'm an expert in Engler 2 or
react but normai an expert of UGS but
out of those you know the 3 hip new
frameworks that are out I do think
vue.js has the most potential just
because the way they have it set up and
their Docs and it's very easy to pick up
and hit the ground running with UJS so
if you like react you know stick with
react but I hope you take some some key
components away from this tutorial
because view GS kind of makes us both
the best practices from angular 2 and
react so you'll see a lot of the same
paradigms in view GS which i think is
good for a beginner because it allows
you to easily transition to other
frameworks in the future so for the
backend we're gonna be using Express GS
which is a very bare-bones framework
that can be used for building restful
api is built on top with a node.js
runtime environment and there's a couple
of other frameworks out there like sales
j/s happy Jas colleges and I haven't
used anything other than sales at work I
personally like Express because super
bare-bones and if you're trying to start
off learning about web applications and
how arrest API works I think starting
with some of those bigger frameworks or
libraries is going to leave you a little
bit confused there's a lot of like
magical generation and hooks and whatnot
going on so for this tutorial we're
gonna start with Express and just kind
of walk you through how to create a
restful api that connects to my sequel
database to store certain things so that
kind of wraps up the overview let's go
ahead and start building out a project
in I'll go ahead and talk about what I'm
going to be building in this tutorial
all right so I'm gonna start off showing
you a pre-built application which we're
going to rebuild and try to work her way
towards which I created it over my spare
time so basically I created an app
called treta tab tracker which we can
use to track guitar tabs right so
there's a couple of other sites out
there like ultimate guitar tabs or
whatever comm but I wanted to try to
replicate that in something that's a
little bit more user friendly and easier
to use so the app we're going to build
in this tutorial was going to look like
this we have a main page which if you
click browse here takes you to this
songs URL and what this page has is if
you're logged in already which I am over
here I'm already logged in and I'll just
go ahead and log out just to come
demonstrate that so if you are not
logged in the Browse tab allows you to
search through songs so if I wanted to
type in let's say reliance K for an
artist it'll filter search the back end
for that artist if I have searched for
genre it'll show up a search for like
country my other song will show up so
basically the functionality is here we
have this little panel which allows us
to search through songs we have the
songs displayed down here if you were to
click on let's say one of the names or
genres and go ahead updates our filter
here and also get updates a URL query
string now if I were to click view it
takes us into the song in which we have
a link to the YouTube video where we can
listen to the song it has again that
basic information it has some tabs over
here so I can easily go through and you
know play through or try to learn the
song and guitar and then also on the
right we have some
Erick's so super straightforward and
basic application now if I were to log
in go here login has my password and
information saved we get a little bit
more functionality so on the Left we
have our recently viewed so anytime you
click view into one of these we're going
to keep track of what you view before so
you can easily just go to songs that you
viewed in the past and then also we have
a section down here called bookmarks
song so if I were to go into I say
getting in to you and say bookmark you
know bookmark this song for my user
account so now if I were to go back to
the Browse tab I have that song
bookmarked over here and again I can go
back and view that we can also since I
am the owner or the one who posted this
song I can go in and edit this song so
we have their own little edit song panel
or view or route which we can edit the
typical metadata that you have on a song
such as the title artist genre album we
can put a link to the album image and we
can also put a youtube ID which is used
for displaying that embedded YouTube
video and then of course on the right we
have our lyrics and our intro and then
we have an about page nothing special
go back to browse and then lastly we
have the ability to add new song so ever
were to click on this plus arrow over
here we were given a crate song routes
where we can enter in that was same
metadata information and you know it'll
print out red if you don't have a filled
in because these are all required fields
and once you have those set up you can
kick create and it will create the song
for you and in this instance we can't
because we haven't filled out all the
fields so that is an overview of what
we're trying to build very very simple
it's like a very bare-bones web
application but it's still enough
functionality to I think get you past
the stages of being an intermediate or
from being a beginner in transitioning
into an intermediate developer like
we're gonna build all this from scratch
starting with a bare git repo which I'll
actually build in this tutorial so let's
go ahead and get started trying to build
out this exact same functionality
alright so starting off I have my github
account right here so I want to go hook
go ahead and just click on repositories
I want to create a new repository
and I'll name this one tab tracker and
then this will be public I'll make it
MIT so when you one can just grab it and
do what they want with it and a
description will say a view UJS
expressjs web application for keeping
track of guitar tabs so now if I click
create repository github will create
that tab tracker project for me and in
this instance we can click clone or
download I'll go ahead and copy this
link and remember that you can change it
to HTTPS if you don't have SSL setup on
your machine I'm not going to cover up
how to set that up but if you try to
clone it with this SSH and it doesn't
work go ahead and switch it to HTTPS and
try that way but anyway I'm going to go
ahead and copy this link and then I'm
going to go to my console and say get
clone and paste that URL and that will
go ahead and download that git repo
project and put it inside my workspace
folder so now I can go ahead and go into
our CD which is changed directory into
tab tracker and right now I have a
folder at my workspace location called
tab tracker which has absolutely nothing
in it except for a license cool so now
if we go back we can go ahead and open
up our visual studios code editor which
I'm going to open up that same folder
which we just clone so I'll go to
workspace I'll go to tab tracker so now
our visual studios editor is opened up
to that project and we can start
creating and adding files and folders as
needed alright so now at this point we
have a blank project folder now we want
to set up our client or view j/s
application for the front-end so
starting off there is a project called
view - CLI which you can use to kind of
build up template project so in this
case you want to install it using NPM
install global or u CLI so if I were to
copy this command and go back to my
terminal and run it that will install
the view CLI client in this case I
already have installed so I'm really
going to do
now if you read through the docs that
says you can use it by typing view in it
the template name and then the project
name so in this case we can say view in
it webpack and then the name of your
project so I'm gonna save you in it
webpack and the project name is going to
be client alrighty so now that view and
it is done installing we can actually
use it by running view in our command
line so if I were to do a view list for
example that'll tell us all the
different templates we can use to build
up our view applications so in this case
I'll save you and knit webpack because
that's one of them that's specified here
and that's the one that has like all the
goodies that you'll probably need and
then I'll do view a knit web pack and
then the name of the folder I want to
create which is client that's gonna take
you through a walkthrough which asks you
a couple questions like the name of your
project I'll keep it as client part of
the project description keep us default
author yeah whatever
if you build runtime and compiler just
stick with that view router yes yes let
your code yes in es hunting is just
basically the way to keep your code very
consistent so you know make sure you
don't have extra semicolons all your
spaces are lined up and good so I'll do
standard set up unit tests with karma
and mocha sure why not tonight watch
sure why not and now at this point we
have a client folder which you can see
here after I did an LS which lists all
the files in my directory we see we have
a client folder here and I were to go
into the client folder and list out we
have now a bunch of different files
which are kind of used for running our
view application and then a better way
to visualize this if I were going
through my tab tracker and go to the
client folder again we have a bunch of
files that are built up from the view
and knit command and a lot of these
aren't to worry about like this is just
pre baked boilerplate project set up
which you don't need to worry about you
might need to later on as you get more
advanced with like sitting with pack and
setting up your build and whatnot but
for the most part we have a project that
is ready to go but before we can
actually do anything we need to install
all of our NPM dependencies or no
dependencies so if we were to look at
this package that JSON file and if
you're not familiar what with what this
is package law Jason is a way for the NP
project to understand what dependencies
your project needs so we have a
basically JSON file which has a list of
dependencies and dev dependencies so
right now none of these are installed on
our machine right so what we need to do
first before we can even try to run our
front-end application is we need to go
back to our terminal and go ahead and
just run MPM install and what that's
going to do is is going to go off to the
NPM repository and it's going to fetch
every single package which is declared
in this file it's going to install it
locally into a node underscore modules
folder inside of this client folder here
so basically when we tell our project to
run it knows where to find different
packages such as you know Express our es
Lent our view view router etc and in the
future of this tutorial we're going to
go ahead and add more dependencies as
our project becomes more complicated so
we're gonna go ahead and let that run
and might take a little bit of time
because it's going to download a bunch
of dependencies but after it's done you
don't have to run this again unless
you're trying to update modules or
something in the future alright so now
that npm install is done running i'm
just gonna show you what a version of
node i'm using I'll do node - - version
and I'm on version 8 - 1 so I recommend
that you have the same version of node
or Beyond at least version 8 or the
latest version just so that you're not
running into issues because this will
change in download different
dependencies and build them up depending
what version you're note on so again
make sure you're in node version 8
points something at least but at this
point all the modules are done
installing we should be able to see that
node modules folder locally so if I were
to LS grep node modules we see that we
have a folder called node modules now
and just to visualize that inside our vs
code editor we have a node modules which
has all of those dependencies and
they're sub dependencies added to that
project folder which is pretty big right
so all these plus all their sub
dependencies and whatnot are inside this
folder
and that's just you know a little bit
background information it's good to
understand how this is being set up but
just know that this is where all our
dependencies are coming from so when we
import stuff in the future you know that
basically we're just going into these
sub projects and downloading and using
their source code right so now all the
node modules are installed at this point
we can actually run npm run dev which is
going to start up our view JSF front-end
server and the reason we can run NPM run
dev is because if you look at that
packages a JSON file over here we see
that we have a script section in the
inside that script section we have a
line called dev so I could do MPM run
dev npm run start npm run build or any
of these and what that's going to do is
going to execute a command behind the
scenes called node build dev server
which basically builds up our source
code and loads up a HTML web browser and
points it to our server so now if I go
back to my browser we see that magically
we have a chrome browser pointed at our
view jeaious application and everything
is ready to go
cool so at this point just to recap we
cloned a github repo locally torrent
machine we use view CLI to kind of build
up a boilerplate project which can be
used to create a view J's front-end
application and then finally we did an
NPM install to make sure we have all the
dependencies we did NPM run dev which
went ahead and started our web server
and our UJS application and now we have
a tab which is ready to go to see the
view JSF application running so I might
seem like a lot of work but remember
it's a one-time thing we don't have to
do any of that stuff again other than if
you wanted to start up your server I
give you shut down your computer and
come back the next day you just need to
run npm run dev and everything will be
ready to go for you so now at this point
we've done a lot of work so it's very
good to make sure you always commit your
changes like as small changes that
usually make it very often commit them
to your github repo so in this case if I
were to you will get status we see that
we have a bunch of changes well in this
case
a subfolder because we just added
something so I'll go back says that we
have a client folder added and what we
want to do is we actually want to add
all the changes that we've done we want
to go ahead and make a commit and give
us some you know initial message so I
said let's just go ahead and say and
that the UJ has application using view
CLI so that's going to go ahead and add
or add all of our files to the staging
area of our local git repo and it's
going to make a commit so we see that
all these changes were added to our
commit and now lastly we want to go
ahead and push those changes to our
master branch on the remote origin repo
so basically at this point recap we
added all the files we made a commit
with this specific message and then we
push it all to our remote origin repo
which is on github so now if I were to
go back to my project on github refresh
the page we see that client is now there
we have all those files inside of our
client folder of the branch master and
then if I were to go to our recent
commits here we have two commits and the
last commit we did in it the view J's
application using view CLI which if you
remember is the exact same message that
we've put up here and now if I were to
click into this I can see all the
different changes that happened with
this commit right a ton of stuff not
really useful because there's just so
many files so make sure your commits are
small and make sure you do them often so
again that was a kind of quick overview
of how to use git make sure you commit
often and make sure your commits are
pretty small and then that was also
demonstrating how you can see your
changes in github so if you're not
familiar with git or github or all these
things continue watching and I think
after some time this will start the
click and make sense as you get used to
continuously committing to a remote repo
but if you feel lost at any point be
sure to pause and go read up on some
information about get about NPM about
view about whatever you want but at this
point let's go ahead and move
- setting up the back-end project or or
pretty much setting up the expressjs
back in REST API
okay so what I like to do in my project
is we're going to have the client code
and the server code separated but in
different folders of our git repos so if
you see here we have a client folder I
want to go ahead and make a server
folder which is going to hold all of our
server code so that the client and the
server don't overlap it's a little bit
easier to manage and deploy separately
and sometimes you make separate git
repos in general with your client having
a different repo and your server have a
different repo but for the sake of this
tutorial let's keep it straightforward
to have a client and a server fold
server folder with a very simple you
know divide or separation between the
two so I went ahead and made a server
folder and if I were to go ahead and go
into that I'm going to go ahead and
split the tab here and typically I have
my client on the left so I can do like
NPM run dev here they have the clients
always running and then on the right I
can just go ahead and do CD into the
server folder let me just fix that
really quick because that auto load in
my browser so now that's in this case
remember the left is just our view GS
application running so we don't need to
worry about this left tab anymore
the right tab is where we're going to
have all of our server code or Express
GS code so we have a blank folder here
nothing in it and I can visualize that
by going to here we see that we have
nothing inside the server tab the first
step we want to do with initializing a
new you know server project is we want
to enable it with NPM so we need another
package of JSON file which we can create
doing NPM in it
- f-for force and basically that's just
going to create a pipes a JSON file and
put it inside that server folder so now
I see I have a package.json file here no
big deal we're familiar with this as a
scripts and as a test and what we want
to do is first of all we're going to
install something called node Mun which
is something very useful for
continuously restarting your server so
I'll do MPM install and - hi
save node Mon we also want to install
let's go set you guess lint alright so
now that those two packages are done
installing what we can do is go back to
that servers package JSON file I'm going
to go ahead and just delete that test
and put in two lines I'm going to do a
start command close this we have a start
script which pretty much is going to run
node man over some file so right now we
don't have an apt ideas created but
we'll do so in a second and it's going
to run a linter over our code and then
it's going to run our server
now this don't I would say don't really
worry about this this is kind of getting
into the weeds of like your setup but
just know that we're just gonna add
these they're just gonna work we need to
set it and forget it not worry about
anymore and then later down the road you
can learn more about NPM and how NPM
scripts and node min works and all this
other stuff so again we're hitting you
with a lot of information at once but I
think that's good so that you have
exposure to you know how a full stack
web application works so at this point
let's go ahead and make a new folder
here and we're gonna call it source and
inside that source folder we'll make a
new file called a Padilla's so inside
this app dot JS file we want to define a
web application so just to kind of start
off I can say console dot log hello
and now if I were to save that file let
me make sure everything looks good
okay so save the package.json file we
saved the API J's file and if we were to
go back to our terminal we should be
able to do an NPM start command because
you remember in that package so jason we
have a start script and there's a
there's a couple of keywords like start
which you don't need to do run I
technically I could do npm run start but
in this case since its start which is a
special keyword i can just do npm start
hopefully this works we might run into
an error let's see it says it can't find
es lint
that's because I forgot to run and
initialize for Uslan so let me just go
ahead and run that really quick so if I
were to go to node modules es Lent and
then should be like a bin file all right
so that's kind of a little bit of setup
so basically remember we do the npm
install we install dias lint so now I
basically just want to run the es lint
script so that it creates a
configuration file for us to use so I'll
do node I'll pass it a file that I want
to run and then I'll pass a flag called
the NIT and when we do this it's going
to give us a prompt and I'm just going
to say use a popular star style guide
I'm gonna say use a standard style guide
which format JavaScript and so I'll give
this a second to finish running all
right so now that hasn't done we should
be able to do an impious tart which will
spin up no daman it'll run and lentor
over our code and then it will start our
server so in this case yes lint ran and
it says too many blank lines at the
beginning the file max of one is allowed
so if I go back to here and just remove
those blank lines save it our project
should restart it should run the linter
over that file and again print out any
more errors this is a new line required
at the end of the file but not found
right so now at this point no demands
should pass lint and then our app runs
and it prints out hello
and then our app will finish because
that's basically all our app does at
this point remember we have a node
script that just prints out hello and
then it's done
okay so let's take a breather little
recap we made a server folder we did npm
init force to create that package that
JSON file we installed two dependencies
which were node mon Annius lint in fact
these are probably deb dependencies so i
could just put them down here no biggie
and then we created those two scripts we
have the start script in the lint script
in which start is going to run node bond
over our apps JS file this is our main
entry point make sure you remember this
is the key key information and then
we're going to also run lint over that
all over all of our javascript files and
then of course you we created our app
dot JS file here which just prints out
hello
so again has a lot of work just to set
up a little project and there are other
you know ways to generate an express
package on the back end but i decided to
take a you know from a scratch approach
for the back end just so you have more
exposure to npm you know creating files
creating projects crane scripts versus
the vgs stuff there's a lot of stuff
going on with web pack which i don't
even want to deal with or teach so i
think it's better to use a generator for
the front end because there's a lot of
stuff the back end you could use a
generator or you could get your hands
dirty and try to learn how to do it by
hand and that's what we're gonna do in
this case with the express server
already so now in this case we can just
go ahead and do ctrl C to close out of
that infinite writing no daman script
again no daman we'll just watch our
javascript files and then if we save or
change any of those files it's going to
restart a server and we'll see how
useful that is in a second but to start
off what we need to do is start
installing a couple of those
dependencies that will need to create an
Express application so to start off
we're going to need an application or a
module called Express or at anyone
called body parser we're going to need
one called cores already new one called
Morgan which is good for printing out
logs and then I think that's good enough
to start off with so let's go ahead and
install those No
Tennessee's we just installed a couple
of dependencies not that big of a deal
we assumed that done in the past we add
- - save to make sure it's added to our
package Jason here now if we go and we
have those four dependencies added to a
package Jason let's see so now at this
point we can actually start building up
a very basic Express Jas server so if I
were to do an NPM start again I'm just
to get everything you know ready to go
and running what we need to do is go
back to our app dot J's file and let's
go ahead and start importing some of
those modules that we just imported or
installed right so first we can do a
caused Express is equal to require
Express we can do a constant body parser
is equal to require body
- parser and basically we're just
requiring those same modules verbatim
which you can see here on the right side
where we do require and then putting
them to some type of environment
variable or not environment variable but
putting them to a constant or variable
here and basically what this is doing is
it's going to dive into that node
modules folder it's going to find the
package called Express or cores so right
here you see this one called cores and
it's going to find the main file and
just include it here so in this case if
I were to look at packages Jason of
course should be a main one here which
is Lib index a Jas and basically what
that's going to do is when you acquire
cores it's going to go ahead and just
grab that course package of course it
closed down it's going to grab this
index file and pretty much put whatever
it exports into this file so again we're
learning more stuff about how modules
work in node.js but it's probably super
confusing right now but it'll make more
sense and down the road as we start
using it more and so finally it's just
finish off with you know declaring or
requiring that last package we installed
called Morgan now at this point we have
an app which has these four dependencies
included so let's build up an Express
app so I can say Const app is equal to
Express
and that's going to build us an express
server which again is just a very basic
web application that's used for building
up rest end points or whatever type of
end points you want and then we want to
start enabling some of those packages so
that we can easily hit our back in and
have logs printed out cores we don't
have to really worry I'll think I can
talk about that later body parser is for
allowing you to process JSON data very
easily so you can do app use first of
all I'll say use the body or the log use
the log generator called Morgan and then
this is something that if you look at
the Morgan Docs it says pass a string of
combined that have it print out it logs
in a certain way we'll see it in a
second app don't use body parser JSON
basically it's saying allow our Express
app to easily pars any JSON requests
that are sent in and then we'll say
after I use cores to allow any host or
client to access this not going to talk
more about cores but pretty much unique
cores if you want a server to be hosted
on a different domain and you want any
clients from around the world to hit
your server and it's kind of a security
risk to have it enabled so just if you
do have it enabled make sure you have a
good no security covering your
application and finally at this point we
can just do app dot
listen whoops and then we can say
process that you need port or port 8081
so at this point if I were to save this
file and hopefully I don't have anything
wrong with the actual code I've been
typing but save the file it's going to
lint my code and it's going to restart
my server so the server is running at
this point but unfortunately there's no
way to hit it because they don't have
any endpoints so I'm going to go ahead
and just create a very very simple
endpoint called get on status in what we
want to do is just return something so
here is how you define routes and
Express right so you give it the method
that you want to post or you want to use
so in typical HTTP requests you can do a
get request if you do a post request you
can do put
pache you to delete I think there's some
others but these are the main five but
basically we're doing app dot the name
of whatever command so in this case
we'll do a get request to a status
endpoint now I should use slash status
and then once we get a request on our
server with that in point what we can do
is just send something back so I'll say
res dot status or red sauce in go ahead
and send back some message objects to
say hello world
okay so delete all that stuff save this
hopefully it works every started it
seems like it's working so now at this
point I'm going to show you yet another
tool so if you give me one second
actually before I could actually use do
this so we have an app or running on
port 8081 right so we should just be
able to go on a chrome go to 881 and do
a slash status and we see here we get
message helloworld back so this shows or
demonstrates that we have a server
actually running on port 8081 it's
handling an endpoint called slash status
when it gets a request is going to go
ahead and send back a JSON object which
has attributed and then the string hello
world exclamation mark if we go here we
just saw that it gets returned to our
browser when we hit this get endpoint
and by default when you do a request in
your Chrome browser is going to do the
default of a get request so let me
demonstrate another application we can
use the kind of test out our back in so
I'm going to go ahead and load up an app
called postman which you can download
from I think the chrome app store give
me one second it's loading up right now
actually I just I just saw a little bug
so it's printing out combined here it's
supposed to be combined so let me go
ahead and change that and save that and
just to show that what that does is now
if I were to hit this endpoint we
actually get some you know some logs it
tells us what device hit us
he got hit by chrome worse than sixty
whatever it was to the end point slash
status it returned a 304 or something
and then I think it also tells you how
long the end point took but anyway
that's what this Morgan lagers doing
just kind of it you know went off on a
tangent there but to kind of demonstrate
another way to test your back-end API
you should download I think there's one
called arrest clients this one is called
postman it's a very useful tool and I
think it's invaluable that you actually
use it but basically allows you to do
different requests so I can say do a get
request to that status endpoint so I do
this it says hello world I can go ahead
and save that to my tab tracker so if I
would say that's a tab tracker I can
easily just load up my application and
then you know grab that endpoint and
test it whenever I want but basically
you can chose the URL you want to test
you can choose the different methods
that you want to send to it you can
define headers you can define bodies so
if I would do a post I could define like
a JSON body here or upload a file via
this is a very very useful application
and I highly suggest you download it
because it's very helpful to test out
endpoints as you create them and as you
debug them so again going back I'll just
go ahead and close out of that and we'll
come back to this in a little bit as we
create more endpoints and stuff that
gets a little bit more complicated but
for now again let's just do a nice
little recap so going to the code we
created an Express application is
running on port 8081
and this is just allows us to overwrite
that port if you want to using
environment variables which we'll cover
probably later on but basically we
created a status in point when we hit it
it sends back this and I think I already
covered that so pretty much wraps up
setting up a client using view j/s and
then setting a server which is going to
use Express GS and both of these are
going to get a little bit more
complicated down the road we're going to
add a lot more logic lot work endpoints
a lot more files but it
good to know that it's very easy to set
up using generators it's also good to
know how to set up a project yourself
using just you know MPM install look
through NPM and find what packages you
want and install them and again now we
just did a bunch of work on the server
side so let's go ahead and go back and
we can add those so get add all get
commit actually that was probably a
mistake we want to go ahead and do a git
ignore file first so that we don't
upload every single node modules that we
just installed so this message I'll say
add everything I don't get commit and
say setup of the express Jas server and
then I'll go ahead and push that to our
back in or push that to github and again
if I were to go to get up here refresh
the project we now have a server folder
at this location with that same you know
app Tijs that we've built up so I mean
hopefully this wasn't too complicated it
might have been a lot of information at
one time but I think as we continuously
add new functionality in the process I'm
going to do is add functionality to the
front end have it point to the back end
and then implement the back and end
points that we're trying to hit right so
we're going to keep on doing that for
every single page and every single
feature and panel inside the front end
so it should end up clicking overtime so
with that being said let's go ahead and
get started building the first piece of
functionality for vue.js application and
that's going to be a register page or a
register route okay so to start off we
want to be able to access or do these
type of get requests and post requests
against our Express j/s application so
one MPM module we should install on the
client just remember this is in the
client folder we want to go ahead and
install a package called Axios which is
a library which can be used for doing
those HTTP requests to a back-end
so while that's installing let's go
ahead and move over to our client folder
here and what we can do is inside the
source folder I'm going to go ahead and
create a folder called services and then
inside here I'm going to create a a file
called a PJs and what this is going to
be used for is basically setting up some
type of connector which can be used to
hitting up the back end so I'm going to
go ahead and first of all import that
Axios library that we're installing or
importing and now we want to have this
file give back a connector so if I were
to go here and just do let's see so this
is a function and we need to return a
connector so what I can say is return X
you just create and then that's going to
take in a couple of things so first of
all we need a base URL and that's going
to 0.2 our back-end API all right so
that should make sense we're saying
create a SAN Axios object which is going
to point to our back-end URL of 8081
and this API thing can be used for like
hitting our different endpoints
so now that we've created that we can go
ahead and create a new folder or file I
mean called authentication service j/s
and what this is going to be used for is
basically hitting that register endpoint
that we haven't yet built but we're
going to build in the future so I'll say
import API from services slash API so
now we have an API object that's
imported from that API file that we
created here which is basically just
going to be this X US object and now we
can actually just deep export a object
that has a couple of methods so in this
one I'll just say register
credentials so basically what we want to
do is have a object which allows us to
call a register method which will hit
that register end point which we haven't
yet built yet so if I were to do
something like this basically what we're
saying is this authentication service
ojs is going to export an object that
has a register method to it and then we
can call this like so we can say
authentication untick a ssin service dot
register and then we can pass it let's
say email at gmail.com and then password
can be like 1 2 3 4 5 6 so basically
this is how we call this method from
another file and we'll see you this in a
little bit when we start building out
that registered endpoint and then
basically what this is doing is we're
gonna pass that email and password to
this post method of the Axios module
which is going to do a post request to
the register end point on our Express
server and then is going to use those
credentials so what we can do here is go
to the back end now and if we were to
create a endpoint called register
instead of using get so we say post
register and then let's just go ahead
and send back a message that says your
user was registered have fun
so now we can hit this register in point
with a post request it should return
this message to us and then you should
see how that kind of links up to what
we're doing we're doing a post request
to the register endpoint and we're
sending in some credentials in fact if
we wanted to access those credentials we
can go back to our rest service and we
can say we could actually say like hello
and then the name of the email so wreck
that body on email close this so we can
see what's going on so now if we were to
send in that email and password payload
to this register endpoint it's going to
send back a Hello your user was
registered to have fun and just to
visualize that with postman because
remember I said it's very useful to use
postman if we were to go to this
register changes to post change this to
JSON and I'll say email is testing at
gol Calm keep forgetting that this needs
to be real JSON and then password is one
two three four five six if ice to a sent
there it returns back from their
back-end hello testing at gmail.com your
user which registered to have fun so I'm
going to click I'm going to go ahead and
save this let's say register a new user
so now we have an in point color
register a new user I'm going to go
ahead and delete this one because we're
not using up so again this kind of shows
you how useful postman is we don't have
a UI yet so it's good to make this or
use postman to kind of test your
endpoints and then once we get the UI we
can start getting those endpoints and
see how it actually works
all right so again a little recap on our
back end we have a register in point
which takes a post request and it will
return a message with the email that we
provided in the payload and then a
little information you can access the
payload using rec that body dot email on
your express server and then for the
front end as a recap we created two
files we create the API which returns in
Axios object that points to a certain
URL and then we created this
authentication service which allows us
to call a register method on it which
will simply post whatever object that we
pass into it down here so this is how
you call it we say authentication
service that register we passes some
JSON object and in this case we're
passing an email and password to be used
later on so let's go ahead and actually
start implementing a UI to be to use for
them this authentication service because
we have like the whole behind-the-scenes
stuff ready to go we have the back and
ready to go and we have some methods in
our JavaScript front-end for how you
kind of communicate with that back in ok
so I don't kind of like jumping all over
the place and jumping from the client to
the server and back and forth and I
think that is a good way to kind of get
you exposed to all the different things
that happen in full stack development
like this is how I kind of work
naturally I'm not just like I like to
implement the backend first sometimes or
implement the front-end and then
integrate them together with a little
piece of functionality so to start off
what we need to do is inside the UI we
want to be able to hit a log or a
register in point so if I were to try to
get a register here it doesn't work
because there is no registration in
point so our first task is we need to
build a register in point in register
components so we can display so to start
off go ahead and close out these because
you don't need these anymore so if I
were to go to our router inside our view
GS basically this is the functionality
or the code which designates how do you
hit different routes so in the URL
basically if we hit the path slash it
takes us to a
hello view or hello component so what we
want to do is we want to make a new path
I could click sorry about that so which
basically we want to have a register
path it's going to be called a register
and then we want to display a register
component so right now we don't have a
register component so let's go ahead and
just copy that and say register so if I
were to say this this will probably fail
because we don't actually have a
register component declare it anywhere
so now at this point we can go to the
components folder we can say you know
just I like the copy and paste existing
code so I'll go ahead and just rename
this one to a register dot view and then
inside here we can just make a very base
like div get rid of all this jazz we
don't need this don't need that hmm
let's see technically we don't need data
at this point and we don't need any of
these styled scripts yet boom so we have
a very bare-bones view jeaious register
component which if I were to say let's
say I'll just say like h1 register so
now if I say this I go and we have a
register page here in fact I'm not sure
why this giant views here I think it's
because I need to go into the main app
file here and again just get rid of that
I don't mean I don't really need that
stuff okay so I get a cool thing with
the view or yeah view j/s the whole like
view CLI product that we set up anytime
you save your file it will refresh and
hot reload your different things that
change so that's just good to know it
makes it super easy to use so now at
this point what we want to do is inside
of a register component we need to have
two different things so we need a
let's say an input field and that's
going to be a type of text and then I'll
say name is email type is actually type
should be email right so basically we
need a register page which has a email
section and it has a password section it
may be a button that says register so
what I'm gonna do is go ahead and do
those three things so I'll say give me
an input box which has a placeholder
email if I were save this we get an
input that says email in it I'm gonna go
with it go ahead and go here we need
something called password see that boom
we get a password and this is just super
super basic HTML with no styling and
I'll go back through and style this with
probably material design in a second and
then lastly we want a button and that's
going to have let's say register all
right so we have an info box called
email we have a input box for password
when you have a register button so at
this point what we actually want to do
is inside view j/s what you can do is
you can bind the HTML to your controller
so basically everything inside the
script tag is your controller and you
can kind of bind your HTML using special
keywords as attributes which will kind
of link things together so I mean they
say it's bad practice to kind of use
two-way bindings but I don't necessarily
think that's true as long as you keep it
like bass inside your component
I mean well we'll use a view X in a
little bit you know I'll spell that out
there's a framework called view X which
is kind of like the flux way of doing
things react does it very similar with
redux and we'll use that later on for a
couple of key store related objects but
for now what we want to do is just do a
V model and set that to email here and
do the same thing down here for
and basically what's happening is it's
saying when view runs go ahead and grab
this input find any type of property or
data or something called email and bind
it so now down here if I were to say
email is equal to a blank string
password is equal to a blank string and
save that
right now it's putting in like autofill
settings that's really annoying so I'm
just going to go ahead and put ABC one
two three so if I save that we see that
those are put into our input box so
what's happening behind the scenes as
the v-model is the two-way binding
school is saying set this inputs value
to whatever this is and vice versa if I
were to type into this input go ahead
and update this down here so what what
can do is kind of demonstrate that is
I'm gonna go ahead and say watch email
and whenever the value of email changes
I'll say console dot log email has
changed value so now at this point in my
console down here whenever this changes
it's going to go ahead and print out
email has changed and that's just kind
of the demonstrate how the two-way
binding works as I type into this input
box my data model is updated in
vice-versa if my data model is updated
so I could do another thing so I'll say
mounted and that's basically whenever
this view component is mounted onto the
page I'm going to run a command it's all
right now just to set timeout of hundred
seconds in fact I need to do function
because I need to use this so I could
say this dot email is equal to a hello
world I call so make sure this is a fat
arrow basically when the page loads
after about two seconds what we're gonna
do is change email to ABC and this will
demonstrate what happens with reactivity
and health if the data model changes the
actual view will change so if i refresh
the page you see that it starts with ABC
and then after two seconds it changes to
hello world so again this was a good
demonstration of how the two-way binding
on B model works for input boxes so
basically what we're trying to do here
is when we click the register button we
want to hit the register in point with
some data and do something so now what
we can do is just go ahead and get rid
of all this you know temporary border
plate code and we want to add a listener
to this so I could say on click we want
to say register so basically if anyone
clicks this register button is going to
go ahead and call a register
method so down here I can say methods I
can say click or I can say register you
could say I'll see you register button
was clicked get rid of all this get rid
of all the watch because that was just
kind of for demonstration and get rid of
mounted and now if I were to save this
when we click that register button with
some values so to put some random values
and click register we see that it now
calls register button was clicked and
then we have the username and password
so at this point it should make sense as
to why we need that what we can do with
that so if we can go up here we could
simply import that authentication
service from if you remember that
services authentication service here
import that service and then what we
could do is just call register on it and
say email is equal to this dot email
password is equal to this dot password
and then I'm going to use a weight and
async here because I think it's much
better than using promises these days
and I could say response is equal to
that so basically what we want to do is
call that end point remember there's a
register end point on our node service
we're going to pass an email and
password and then we're gonna wait until
it give it a response back and once we
get that response we can just go ahead
and print out response time data save
this file this should refresh and then
we click register with that and we get
back a message hello see cyber at
gmail.com your user was registered to
have fun and again we can go to our
endpoint hero node and we see that every
time we click that register button it's
hitting our node server right I keep
doing that a couple times so we're
getting our node server requests and
we're sending a request to that register
endpoint alright so I think this is a
good stopping point I think we you know
covered setting up an entire project
front in the backend with few J s and
expressjs for the backend and then we
also set up how to create a very simple
login or registration page using the
exos or xeo some library and then also
defining that end point in our Express
application so at this point remember
after you've made some progress it's
very good to go ahead and commit your
changes in this case I'm going to go
ahead do it in vs studio so that I'm not
you know overwhelming you with
command-line lingo so what we could do
here is just go ahead and say add
everything so and then a commit message
would be setting up the registration
page and they go ahead and push those
changes to the master branch and again
if I go to my github refresh the page I
should be able to see that we now have
that register in point here so all of
our code is now on github we're at a
good State and I think we can stop this
video for today and come back later and
start implementing some more stuff all
right thanks for watching